so apparently your creator of a lot of
things okay so the game is called can
you believe Noah invent it and I'm gonna
tell you some of the things that they
say you've invented what do y'all saying
about me a visit
[Music]
can you believe Noah I've never heard
can you believe Noah invented being
sentimental they gave you a lot Noah I'm
like super sentimental I believe that
was okay you gave in to that I could
take that when's the last time you cried
during a movie a movie mm-hmm we could
go which one I was watching it with my
friend and she started crying and then
like I looked at her and she looked at
me and I had tears welling up and she
was like who held who after that cry
though oh it was like it's fine can you
believe Noah invented floral shirts yeah
yeah you rock one pretty well oh can you
believe and Noah invents it looking good
in Polaroid okay I wish all right can
you believe Noah invented the word
meditate no send the record straight
there's a brand invented meditation
everybody knows that I can agree you
might have invented this so this is
before the emoji age and all of that can
you believe that Noah invented hard eyes
oh that's the glue should you say I I
thought it would have been like that
they're like no you are walking emoji I
love it all right can you believe that
Noah invented boyfriend material
no why do you say that I'm not boyfriend
material
how are you not I got a wildling do okay
so top three things that make someone
girlfriend material
really good at communicating so
communicating effectively being present
like in the moment and you know whether
that's like when we're together we're
together and someone who's dedicated to
herself last one and I know this was
true
can you believe Noah invented smiling I
would say you're pretty good at it now
think about it this is that stop love
you know why they love you and we love
you thank you so much for stopping in
and talking to us about all things going
on with you were so proud of you
[Applause]
[Music]